[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre d'état vous avez
décidé d'augmenter une nouvelle fois la
taxe sur les carburants et assumer cette
position de manière constante
il est grand temps que vous preniez
conscience de l'injustice qu'engendre
votre politique au lieu de vous
contenter de mesures de circonstance en
réaction à la colère des français
vous êtes le chef d'orchestre d'une
fiscalité punitive
à défaut de dérouler la partition d'une
écologie positive unique clés d'une
transition énergétique harmonieuse
capable d'emporter l'adhésion des
français
cette politique confiscatoire et le
point d'orgue de ce que vous essayez de
vendre au français comme étant la
symphonie du nouveau monde
alors je vous le demande monsieur le
ministre quelles nouvelles orientations
décisives et stratégiques
proposez vous pour être à la hauteur des
enjeux de la transition écologique que
l'urgence climatique exige merci
le parodien de ce genre le saut françois
de rugy ministre d'état ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire pour
deux minutes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur us ont il ya quelques années
vous aviez remis un rapport à la suite
d'une commission d'enquêté sénatoriale
sur la pollution de l'air et vous aviez
courageusement avec votre collègue de
l'époque leila aichi chiffrer les dégâts
de la pollution de l'air vous aviez
évaluer avec les autorités compétentes à
45 mille morts prématurées par an
aujourd'hui santé publique france a
évalué à réévaluer ce chiffre à 48 mille
morts prématurées par an et à la
pollution de l'air vous aviez évaluer
les dégâts de la pollution de l'air à
plus de 100 milliards d'euros
vous aviez appelé à l'action et vous
aviez raison moi j'ai vu ces dernières
années les atermoiements sur les
questions à la fois de la pollution de
l'air et du climat
je me souviens et je le dis aussi aux
sénateurs montaugé qui posait la
question et surtout dans sa réplique
après ma réponse en 1998 le gouvernement
avait envisagé la convergence essence
diesel avait commencé à l'amorcé il a
stoppé net en 2000 en 2008 on a incité
les français à acheter des petites
voitures au diesel et on a atteint un
pic en 2012 à 72 % du parc de voitures
neuves
les ventes de voitures neuves qui
étaient diesel et ensuite il ya eu lieu
diesel guette et il y a eu un début de
réorientation fiscale et nous assumons
la convergence fiscale essence diesel
car en effet il faut libérer les
français et de la consommation de
pétrole en général et du diesel en
particulier et nous avons obtenu des
résultats et je ne les revendique pas
pour moi même c'est une action continue
aujourd'hui les voitures neuves le
diesel ne représente plus que 36%
ça ce sont des actions concrètes et nous
amplifions les choses avec la prime à la
conversion et elle ne rate pas sa cible
puisque 70 % des automobilistes qui
changent de voiture avec cette prime
sont des ménages non-imposables et 80%
des véhicules sous la glace grâce à
cette prime sont des véhicules diesel
donc oui il faut agir
si maintenant et avec constance sa
collègue la veille minutes 06 pour
répliquer je veux souligner monsieur le
ministre
l'incohérence finalement de votre
politique de taxation énergétique fait
de volte/face permanent je vais précis
en 2019 moins de 20% des prélèvements
faits sur les carburants seront
consacrés à des actions écologiques et
environnementales et pour la seule
hausse des taxes pour 2019
non seulement vous mettez pas un euro de
plus mais les dépenses consacrées baisse
de 400 millions d'euros autrement dit
vous prenez plus aux français et vous
donner moins à la transition écologique
le président de la république affiche la
volonté de taxer moins le travail et
davantage de carburant
mais le carburant permet aux français
d'aller au travail votre ministre des
transports le rappel 80% du territoire
national n'est pas peu ou mal desservies
par une offre de transport alternative à
la voiture
les français n'habitant pas les
métropoles ne mérite pas d'être assigné
à résidence
monsieur le ministre les gaulois
réfractaires ont bien vu et ont
parfaitement conscience qu'en marchant
sur la tête vous voulez les rouler dans
la farine et conclure à juste raison et
ne l'acceptent pas alors au travail
parce qu'il ya urgence à agir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]